what's going on everybody Ian Hart is
here on behalf of PFF welcome to BR
fantasy going over all things wave of
wire here on this lovely Tuesday but
before we get into that I want to go
over some of the biggest shishas of week
two by shishizami nullified touchdowns
drop touchdowns passes that should have
been for touchdowns but weren't because
they were inaccurate basically all the
cool stuff that you see when you watch
the games but don't necessarily get in
the Box for when you're actually looking
through it at the end so just want to
highlight some big ones you can find a
full list of these as always on pff.com
every Tuesday but guys Chris olave New
Orleans Saints rookie wide receiver 320
air yards 80 receiving yards 320 air
yards if you don't know air yards they
just track the distance where it goes
from the quarterback's hand to the
intended target so if it's 50 yards down
field and it's incomplete 50 air yards
320 is so Bonkers and when they finally
did connect at the end of the game
alapee holds in a nice 50-yard catch he
fumbles it as he's going through the
ground so you know one of those games
where it looked great if you could have
told fantasy managers before how many
areas going to get we all want to
stuttered him just didn't work out and
that's why it was a sheesh Sterling
Shepard was wide open for a potential
78-yard house call Great double move he
even drew a penalty on it so you can
argue that you know might have messed up
the timing a little bit sure seemed to
be running a full speed after though
Daniel Jones did Daniel Jones things and
just sailed it Shepard should still be
running at this moment in time Garrett
Wilson Mark Andrews great days at the
office you're not disappointed by
anything they did just realized Garrett
Wilson could have had a third touchdown
before the half mark Andrews almost made
things even feistier there at the end
could have scored at the very end with a
better ball from Lamar Jackson they had
to settle for the Justin Tucker field
goal ended up not being quite enough
drop touchdowns on the day Jamal Avenue
Brandon Cooks Irv Smith and Tyler Higby
on what would have been a gnarly little
side on pass from Matthew Stafford we'll
also know pretty hilarious instance
there for the Ravens they had an 18 play
Drive take 10 minutes at 52 seconds off
the clock zero points after Mike Davis
got stuffed twice about the goal line
Lamar Jackson once and then ultimately
the fumble on fourth down finally though
the biggest sheets of the entire week
goes to Seattle Seahawks wide receiver
one DK Metcalf been a tough experience
going from Russell Wilson to Geno Smith
with that said he had the chance to make
and did arguably make the single best
catch of the season so far downfield one
hand contested coverage DK Metcalf came
down with it unfortunately an illegal
man downfield penalty that had
absolutely nothing to do with the play
wiped it out so I know DeAndre Hopkins a
couple years ago he had one or two
completely absurd one-handed catches
downfield that end up not counting put
DK Metcalf on the list right next to him
final note here before we get into some
good waiver wire stuff is the Broncos
they had a pretty terrible sequence this
is a tough game for Russell Wilson
anytime you see a quarterback go 14 for
31 I think it was you know it's hard to
dress that up into anything better than
just probably being awful but man the
sequence in the second quarter where he
throws a deep on The Courtland Sutton
they draw 44-yard pass interference
almost made a great catch through the
interference what did Russ do next cool
guy move went right back to Sutton on
the very next play on a fade got ruled a
touchdown for the review he actually had
one foot out of bounds next play back to
Sutton no dice once again next play Russ
has a wide open Javonte Williams over
the middle he tries to rock it into him
does not hit Javonte Williams it's a
lineman in the helmet proceeds to shoot
up in the air miraculously falls into
the arms of Kendall Hinton that guy that
played quarterback for one game back in
the covet 2020 season but he couldn't
get two feet in bounds just a completely
incredible drive from the Broncos to not
come away with the touchdown when they
had a good four separate opportunities
to do so that's what happens in the NFL
sometimes though so
thank you everyone for tuning in this is
BR fantasy presented by State Farm and
let's get after the week three Waiver
Wires so looking ahead at everything
that's going on I want to be clear I'm
talking about players that are owned and
50 or less of Yahoo and ESPN leagues so
I understand I can't go into each and
every one of your guys's League settings
you know and just really tell you
exactly what to do so just quickly
before we get into the more obvious guys
I want to list some players that are
owned a more than 50 percent of leagues
but God forbid they are on your waiver
wire go get them so quarterback to
attack of Aloha just saw him with those
six touchdowns and this Dolphins offense
we want exposure to it through two weeks
number one the NFL and play action rate
number one in shift motion rate even if
you don't believe In Tua at this point
it's hard not to believe in Mike Dan
Mike McDaniel Tyree kill and JLM waddle
Running Backs from Andre Stevenson now
the full clear-cut rb2 in New England
after retirees and injuries going on and
we aren't even sure if Damon Harris is
fully healthy at this point could
finally be romander Stevenson season in
New England Jeff Jeff Wilson already
confirmed to be the rb1 San Francisco
without Elijah Mitchell and now at
Tyrion Davis price missing time with the
high ankle Sprint and Trey Lance making
way for Jimmy Garoppolo who should be a
fantasy upgrade for not over Trey lands
but for the rest of 49ers involved
should be more big days ahead for Jeff
Wilson out wide receiver Chris olave
mentioned all those fantasy friendly air
yards he had earlier and Curtis Samuel
two guys that again are owned to more
than 50 percent of the leagues but
relative the other guys we're going to
talk about I would prioritize them and
finally tight end Tyler Higby right now
just really vying for you know the
overall Target lead out the position and
when you look at the offense I fully
agree Alan Robinson should be the number
two here but it's not our choice it's
Matthew Stafford's right now Tyler Higby
after the first top eight or nine tight
ends particularly not with Dalton
Schultz being injured don't be afraid to
get exposure to Iran's offense that hey
hasn't exactly hit the ground running
but if you take away the week one yeah I
know we only have a two game sample size
but let's face it that Bill's defense is
looking like a juggernaut at this point
in time and I think we'll see better
days ahead for Sean McVay and the srams
passing game so Tua ramandre Stevenson
Jeff Wilson Chris olave Curtis [ __ ] and
Tyler higbee waiver wire targets that if
they are out there great go get them and
if not you should go get the following
guys I'm gonna talk about starting with
New York Jets wide receiver Garrett
Wilson mentioned in the opening part of
the show how we almost had a third
touchdown I think fantasy managers or
your wave of wire was pretty happy with
what he was able to get out there and
this is something we've now seen for
back-to-back weeks with Joe Flacco
really treating Garrett not as the
number four wide receiver like his
routes were actually saying he was in
week one but as the legit number one
wide receiver in this offense just based
on when he's getting the ball
pretty cool kind of back-end stats we
got at PFF one of them is the ability to
see who's getting targeted on the
quarterback's first read I like looking
at this stat because it just helps show
okay this is the guy that's actually
getting the plays designed for them
while in Garrett Wilson's case he has 19
first three Targets this season the only
guys with more Cooper cup Jalen waddle
Tyree kill and Devonte Adams pretty
great group to be in the separation
skills are all over the place and really
the only concern for Garrett Wilson is
what life could look like one Zach
Wilson is back because Zach Wilson I'm
not telling you he can't work out you
know it was a bad situation for him last
year we all kind of gave Trevor Lawrence
a pass even though Zach Wilson didn't
get the same pass and I think the Jets
arguably did a better job surrounding
Zach Wilson with talent and the Jaguars
did what Trevor Lawrence going this year
so I'm not saying it can't work out but
man as things stand with you know Zach
being at less than 100 percent it could
be rough so with Garrett
someone that you do need to consider
look ahead for and even though the
ceiling might not be super high I do
still think that you know he's someone
that has a wide receiver three has a
good chance
all right Guys Tyler algier gonna be a
running back and moving forward I'm
going to be starting with the number 10
down to number one so a little bit out
of order to start but you guys can roll
with it so Garrett Wilson my number one
out of the week we're gonna start now at
10 though Tyler algier with the Atlanta
Falcons look the only problem with
algier is his overall upside just he's
one injury away from arguably being a
healthy scratch again if you look at
week one Damien Harris some I'm sorry
Damian Williams former Chief Super Bowl
hero then was on the Bears last year he
was the early down back even working
ahead at Cordero Patterson before he
suffered a rip injury then he got put on
ir and unfortunately he's gonna be out
for a bit so last week Tyler algier got
in on the action actually equaled
corduro Patterson with 10 carries in
that game the question guys and it's why
he's number 10 this list for me I just
don't see the overall upside in Atlanta
they also had Caleb Huntley involved
they also have something named Avery
Williams involved I consider myself guys
pretty knowledgeable about football it's
my job to basically know every player I
could not have told you Avery Williams
was before week one of this season so
Tyler Algiers still 32 snaps last week
theoretically he can't handle all three
Downs you know going into this actual
offseason he was one of just four draft
eligible running backs with a PFF grade
about 70 or more in rushing receiving
and pass block and Damian Pierce was
another guy so if Cordero Patterson gets
hurt I do think Tyler algier you know
would be on the cover of a lot of these
waiver wire discussions but he's already
benefited from one injury it's tough to
have someone you know again as a stash
banking against another injury when we
still could possibly see just algier
Avery Williams when Caleb Huntley make
this three-back committee even if
Cordero Patterson gets hurt so this week
if you need 10 carriers you know you're
in a deep League where things are just
going that way okay he has set up well
against the Seattle run defense has
still learned to play without Bobby
Wagner and Jamal Adams
appreciate you guys in the chat we'll
definitely get to a ton of these
questions once I get to the top 10 but I
definitely want to get through some in
the meantime so from at Jade SEO Kareem
hunt or Clyde Edwards Solaire guessing
that's a start sit one there I do lean
towards Kareem hunt though it's cloudy
versus Hilary he keeps getting the
touchdowns he had the big run last week
but guys the only problem with that we
just need to keep in mind three running
backs involved consistently in Kansas
City Derek McKinnon actually played more
than a cloud ever Solarium week two and
Isaiah Pacheco more in week one I know
the Pacheco one was a little more due to
the game script but with Clyde he needs
to be insanely efficient right now in
order to meet value Kareem hunt still in
just a two running back backfield I
prefer that situation from LeBron James
best wide receiver pickup just set it my
man Garrett Wilson with the Jets he is
going to be the guy we're prioritizing
top at the week from at Colson with
Breeze Murray or Hertz like you know
this is like why is it between McLovin
and Mohammed that is a great problem to
have I would lean just ever so slightly
towards Jalen hurts I mean you go
performance last night you know on
Twitter I call it the most dominant 24
Point performance ever because like I
just couldn't believe looking up at the
end that the Eagles had only scored 24
points obviously Jalen and what he's
able to do on the ground scored a lot
more fantasy points than that so with
collar still again we're already going
over to the consensus top five fantasy
quarterbacks this week but with Kyler
that Cardinals offense has the
borderline Dreadful during the first 30
minutes of each of their first two games
I'm gonna go ahead and take Jalen hurts
and an eagles offense that looks nothing
short of a juggernaut for the time being
real quick at wavy munchie best running
back pickup again if they're out there
with Madre Stevenson and Jeff Wilson if
not as we'll get to Raheem moster is
going to be that guy for me and
Apollonia Noah Brown worth the ab look
there's always a league type there's
always a roster where pretty much anyone
in the league is going to be worth an ad
if you absolutely need six to eight
targets okay it sounds like Michael
Gallup even when he gets back in the
picture is still going to be limited a
little bit in week one but with Noah
brown guys it's still just only a week
or two actual chance for him to uh put
up some numbers so still not gonna have
Dak for a while I think Noah Brown is
someone again if he needed Flex for just
week three okay there are gonna be some
worse options out there but I just think
guys like Garrett Wilson even guys like
Sterling Shepard that we'll get to in a
bit they present better you know overall
upside for the rest of the season
all right number nine on my favorite
wave of wire players to pick up this
week is going to be quarterback Jameis
Winston with the New Orleans Saints have
you guys watched Jameis this year this
is like Peak Jameis Winston experience
maybe not the most entertaining thing
for Saints fans at least in week two but
at least for us casual viewers fantastic
stuff here because right now through two
weeks Jameis has the second highest
average Target death he's top five in
PFS metric Big Time throw rates they are
what they sound like you know Elite
tight window throws downfield he's top
five in those that's really good he's
also bottom five in turnover worthy play
rates so dropped interceptions real
interceptions fumbles all those sorts of
things so we have James simultaneously
making you know some of the best throws
in the league out of top five rate and
also making mistakes at a top five rate
that is entertainment everyone but in
Fantasyland interceptions usually only
count for minus one point so we don't
have to worry about the mistakes as much
as the Saints you know in real life
people have to with James so ultimately
James he's tied for seventh and drop
backs right now the Saints offense is
fourth and pass play rate and non
garbage time time situations like that's
the key here because last season when
James was under center for the Saints in
the first six seven games before he got
hurt their number one receiver was
Marquez Callaway so of course they
weren't going to pass the ball and in
fact they passed the ball at the 32nd
you know highest rate dead last in the
league passing when James was under
Center for him last year it's a new
offense a Lobby Michael Thomas Jarvis
Landry Abba kumara was leaving to end
there last week which could also be you
know just causing them to go to the air
more often the fractures in the back
aren't ideal again if two was out there
I do prefer Tua over Jameis Winston but
just looking at the upcoming matchups
for James to get the Panthers the
Vikings the Seahawks the Bengals the
Cardinals the Raiders and the Ravens and
I'm not saying every single one does the
smash matchup but you look at the ones
Panthers Seahawks uh I would say
Cardinals those were like objectively
poorest defenses now I'm not too worried
about then we got the Vikings the
Bengals the Cardinals again the Raiders
and the Ravens now all of a sudden we
have the sort of shootout potential game
script where James is gonna be forced to
keep his foot on the gas just to keep
the Saints in the game so Jameis Winston
two is not their favorite streamer
favorite waiver ad of the week at
quarterback
number eight favorite ad of the week
this is a pure handcuffed play but Jalen
Warren the backup running back on the
Pittsburgh Steelers so this is one of
those things where I think jalenmore was
on a lot of people's Radars last week
Naji Harris came in early to the week
you know with that foot injury we
weren't sure if he was going to be out
there when it actually came time to play
but by the time Friday came along he
didn't even have an injury designation
so we were good to not worry about Jalen
Warren but even in that week two game we
did see Warren work as the clear-cut
number two running back behind Naji
Harrison if there has ever been just a
pure volume Workhorse role and fantasy
that we can get behind it's been this
Pittsburgh Steelers running back I mean
Le'Veon Bell in the past James Cotter
even when Le'Veon Bell was suspended do
you guys remember old man D'Angelo
Williams Going Bonkers you know just
whenever he got the chance Stefan Ridley
was getting 15 20 touches per game in
these random week 17 spot stars for the
tomlin-led Steelers you know in the
middle of the 2010s and we've seen the
same thing from Matt Canada I ran a
study this off season looking at what
offenses are actually willing to keep
their running back on the field for 90
or more snaps because you know it's 20
22. it's not 2 000 anymore teams almost
always go to the Committees but Steelers
play caller Matt Canada 41 games easily
the highest in the league league where
he left his running back on the field
for over 90 percent of the snap so yes
that was Naji Harris it's not a complete
guarantee that Jalen Warren would get
the exact same workload but again when
we're not just looking at nausea we're
looking at literally almost a decade now
worth of data suggesting that the
Steelers will use one running back and
that's about it Jalen Warren seems to be
one injury away from being that guy so
even if Warren wouldn't be you know the
usage-based rb1 that Naji is right now
he'd be awfully difficult to keep out of
starting lineups of all shapes and sizes
should something happen to Naji Harrison
that's the guy I want like that's why
Jayla Moore is the head of Tyler algiere
who's going to score more fantasy points
this week Tyler I was here like I don't
think Jalen Warren is going to have more
than probably five combined carries and
targets any week that Nashi Harris is
healthy but man first or last guys you
know unless you're in one of those
fantasy leagues or last place has a
terrible punishment in that case you
know maybe we can adjust uh that
strategy a little bit but with Jason
Warren truly he's gonna be on the cover
of every wave of wire article if
something happens to Naji Harris just
based on him already being a little bit
banged up with that workload Jayla
Warren should be on the majority of
rosters already as a handcuff luckily
for you he is not
few more questions from the chat at
rockefella Eno Benjamin or Daryl
Williams the answer is no if you can
avoid it I really thought it was going
to be Eno Benjamin because he was the
only running back being used behind
James Connor in week one last week
though literally split right down the
middle between Eno and Daryl so because
Eno got the nod over Daryl in week one
I'll give you know the slight Edge but
it sounds like James Connor ankle injury
isn't really all that serious to begin
with so I really wouldn't prioritize
either Cardinals running back this week
on the waiver wire
from Outlaw pink trade DK Metcalf or
keep I feel like if you trade him now
you're trading him at the bottom of the
barrel and what we have seen in Seattle
not a good team I get that but Geno
Smith has shown us that maybe just maybe
guys Geno can be below average maybe
some weeks even a little bit above
average and on his worst probably pretty
bad but I don't think the difference
between Geno Smith and guys like Davis
Mills guys like Baker Mayfield you know
I don't think Gino is significantly
worse than them and we don't treat guys
like Brandon Cooks guys like you know DJ
more exactly like they just can't even
be drafting them so DK Metcalf
touchdowns haven't been there touchdowns
haven't been there for Tyler Lockett as
well I still think we're going to see a
lot of games such as last week where
they're forced to really throw the ball
more than they'd like to because of the
game script DK should eventually be
capitalizing more on that again
incredible like 40 plus yard one-handed
catch last week unfortunately got
nullified by that illegal man downfield
penalty
from Old Man Jenkins Jeff Wilson or
James Robinson
tough one
um I'm gonna lean towards assuming
you're talking about just the start set
Jeff Wilson for now without Terry and
Davis price and the picture at Drew
should I keep Russ unless you have a
legit top six quarterback uh Herbert
Lamar Mahomes you know hurts and these
guys yes you absolutely need to keep
Russell I think we'll see bigger and
better days they've had so many near
touchdowns from these first two weeks
I'm not concerned all about this Broncos
passing game moving forward hopefully
they can get a little healthier though
shout out jury Judy and at Mickey Mamba
is Tyler Higby worth a way for wire
pickup the top tight end pickup because
he is just on the field all the time in
LA it's the exact same reason why a lot
of people including myself were hyping
up herb Smith more in the summer Rams
offensive coordinator Kevin O'Connell
coming from LA to Minnesota you just
don't see many offenses either tied in
on the field all the time the Rams and
accordingly Tyler Higby are one of them
all right guys number seven waiver wire
ad of the week I just mentioned tight
ends are on the field all the time Logan
Thomas with the Washington commanders
he's not there just yet but he's about
to be there and it's almost like this
whole Washington just the whole idea
that Ron Rivera consistently allows them
to keep their tight ends on the field
for a hundred percent of the snaps last
year Logan Thomas did it Ricky Seals
Jones did it and also John Bates did it
they do that tight end they refuse to
give Antonio Gibson a three down roll
but this isn't about Antonio Gibson
right here so Logan Thomas was off the
fantasy radar when the season started
because he was recovering from his ACL
started off the year limited 62 snaps
last week though 73 snaps seems like a
matter of when and not if he's right
back up to that near every down roll so
Washington offense this season third in
drop back second and passing yards tied
for first and passing touchdowns like I
don't think this is going to keep up you
know we'll see the clock strike midnight
on Carson once as you know fairy tale
starts of the Season pretty soon I'm
sure with that said at least we now see
that there is a possibility of upside
that was never really on the table with
Taylor monarchies so looking at the
matchup for week three they got the
Eagles who were lucky to only give up
one touchdown to Irv Smith I don't know
if you guys saw that uh you know
Christian Watson has dropped basically
downfield that Irv had could have easily
been a 60-yard house call so not saying
Logan Thomas would get that 60-yard
touchdown should be on the field an
awful lot though and now tight end you
guys look you guys see the available
options out there just having someone
that's going to be running around let
you know 80 plus the quarterback's
dropbacks awfully valuable when it comes
down to it
number six wave of wire ad of the week
is going to be Sterling Shepard
mentioning on the intro of the Show how
he was literally guys just a somewhat
accurate pass from Daniel Jones away
from scoring a 78-yard touchdown last
week sick double move got wide open
Jones couldn't put in near him so now it
was Sterling Shepherds another situation
like Logan Thomas where we were off the
scent and before the season started due
to things that now are completely
reversed so Sterling Shepard coming off
the Achilles we didn't know if he was
going to be healthy not only is he
healthy Juan Dale Robinson is out with a
knee injury not sure when he's going to
be back but there is Tony is seemingly
still in the doghouse we also have Kenny
galde now playing two snaps so Sterling
Shepard's competition is Richie James
and David Sills not a joke sadly for
Giants fans but they keep on winning so
good for them with that said guys
Sterling Shepard fun stat that I heard
of ESPN's Mike Clay start over the years
and I've you know added on to it since
week 11 2018 Shepard has six plus
Targets in all but three of his
non-injury shortened game so this guy is
about as good of a bet as you'll find
you know to get six to eight targets per
week and I know Daniel Jones is under
Center but Shepard could be a viable
wide receiver of three to rest the way
on volume alone not so sure there's
going to be you know super high end
upside there but you can make that case
for a lot of the way for Wired targets
available this week and just in general
guys with everyone I'm talking about you
know even up to our top two guys in
Garrett Wilson and Raheem moster I'm
just not you know willing to spend
usually more about 15 of your Fab on
them so General Fab rule also
don't go too crazy but if you do want
someone don't bid like 20 of your 100
bid 21 bid 22 people love those round
numbers a lot of times you can get
yourself just the guy you want by paying
an extra one or two dollars don't be
afraid to be a little bit unique in that
eventual Fab bid
a few more chat questions here at OC
Stafford or Tua love Matthew Stafford
this week I just think that with that
match up against the Cardinal secondary
that really hasn't slowed down anyone
I'm taking Stafford meanwhile two has
got to face a bills defense that just
looks like freaking juggernauts out
there the way they were able to shut
down those first two offenses I mean
Canada Hill and Company couldn't do
anything last night and I understand
it'd be easy to say like Ah that's just
Ryan Tannehill but they look at Matthew
Stafford in week one no dice
all right guys another wide receiver I'm
looking to add this week my number five
ad Josh Palmer got the touchdown last
Thursday night and that's really been a
regular thing whenever he's gotten a
chance to be out there as a full-time
player so he's now actually had five
career games with at least 60 snaps he
scored in all but one of them and the
only one he didn't in week one I kid you
not you pull up that all 22. got loose
for a 20-yard score on a nice double
move and Herbert tried to throw him the
ball unfortunately got batted down at
the line of scrimmage so it didn't work
out so the good reality in week one that
kind of got lost because Keenan Allen
got hurt Palmer already beat out jail
and Guyton for that number three wide
receiver role in the Los Angeles
Chargers offense so since week one of
last season Chargers wide receivers as a
whole they're number three in rounds the
number seven in targets they're seventh
in receiving yards they're tied for
eighth in receiving touchdowns this is
life as anyone inside the off an offense
led by Justin Herbert I know Herbert
Spangled up with the rib but not
believed to be a long-term issue at this
moment in time so Josh Palmer someone
that whenever Keenan or Mike Williams
get hurt he's a viable if not wide
receiver three option and even without
we're talking about a boomer bus wide
receiver four type so you look at the
upcoming matchups for the Chargers the
Jaguars the Texans the Browns Broncos
Seahawks Falcons again there's some good
cornerbacks out there AJ Terrell and the
Falcons Denzel wore on the Browns but I
mean sign me up for those Jaguars Texans
the Seahawks matchups at a minimum
number four we have a wire ad of the
week New England's Patriots wide
receiver one at this point Jacoby Myers
guys since week one of last season
Jacoby Myers has 149 targets Hunter
Henry 82. 149 versus 82 and not that
much has changed in this overall offense
from then and now Devonte Parker got
added to the equation you know we had Ty
Montgomery out there for a minute but
generally Matt Jones has been thrown to
the same guys both season and Jacoby
just continues to be the number one guy
all we need is for the scoring to
increase and that's for Jacoby and more
so the offense in general we all know
Jacoby's had a hard time finding the end
zone over the years but man this
Patriot's offense ranked sixth in
scoring last year right now they're 29
so new offensive transition you know the
word from training camp the whole time
but has been Mac Jones struggling with
this but if he does get things going a
little bit which again I'm not saying
they're going to be back to being a top
10 unit but 6 to 29th I think it's
reasonable to suggest they can settle
down and finish as more of an average
offense Jacoby should be the guy to
really benefit and this week especially
actually gets that banged up Baltimore
secondary that look I'm not taking
anything away from Tua Tyrique or Jalen
waddle there are a lot of blown
coverages in that game I ain't your Kobe
Myers could be the guy to take advantage
of them this week
three more top wave wire as before I get
to all your guys questions here Brian
Robinson this is a key one for me I
think other than Raheem mostert and I
mentioned Stevenson and Jeff Wilson if
those guys aren't you know available on
your way for a while really consider
going after Brian Robinson he returned
to practice last week he's obviously
coming back from that you know terribly
unfortunate gunshot wound that prevented
him from probably being the Washington
Week one starting running back that's
what they did with their starters in
preseason it's why Antonio Gibson was
working with the kick return team
throughout August maybe that's changed
but his worst case is basically as what
Antonio Gibson is benefiting from right
now something happens to Antonio Gibson
Brian Robinson will be in the rb2
conversation getting all the early down
work while JD mckissick is some of the
pass down work or he starts and he's the
lead early down back and probably kind
of annoying three-back committee but
this is someone that I think everyone's
gonna be talking about next week Brian
Robinson isn't available to come back
from IR until week five out of sight out
of mind go get him this week if you have
the Ross response if you're not worried
about your week three starting lineup I
think Robinson is better than again any
of these other running backs I've talked
about with the exception being my next
guy Raheem mosterts so looking at kind
of just the difference in snaps last
week versus admins now it is the moster
show not saying it's going to be this
way down the road you know we've learned
this now in LA and Miami we have two
back committees that have you know gone
one way in week one gone the other way
in week two so we can't just assume it's
going to go the same way from week two
to week three with that said just some
case and cam makers honestly they went
from being clearly defined backups in
week one to the arguable lead back in
week two so at a minimum that tells me
that they're not a clear backup this
looks more and more like a two-headed
committee so why not take Raheem moster
who's again available in the vast
majority of leagues 57 snaps 11 carries
and three targets with the same exact
route rate as Chase Edmonds last week so
I mentioned this earlier but
betting on Miami like yeah you have your
Tyrique and you have your waddle but
even if you aren't a big fan of Mozart
or Tua be a fan of Mike McDaniel and
this offense number one in play action
rate number one shift motion rate this
is just a good offense that's right now
fourth in scoring in the entire league
that we're gonna want pieces of so bills
Bengals the next two matchups there
could be shootouts Jets and Vikings
maybe that's when you know McDaniel is
really able to sink his teeth in and
just make some easy opportunities for
his players mentioned him at the top but
yes the number one ad of the week
Garrett Wilson two touchdowns last week
could have had three again
none of these guys I'm going crazy with
even Garrett 15 maybe 20 of your Fab
because unfortunately you still have to
share an offense with Elijah Moore with
Corey Davis you know the rest of the
season could also get Zach Wilson back
but hey targets are targets guys and
right now Garrett Wilson is getting fed
targets at an elite level so top 10
waiver wire ads of the week excluding
the guys that are owned and more than 50
of leagues already number one Garrett
Wilson Raheem moster Brian Robinson
Jacoby Myers Josh Palmer Sterling
Shepard Logan Thomas Jalen Warren Jameis
Winston and Tyler algier and all right
guys let's jump into personalized
fantasy advice presented by State Farm
where the personal price plan is all
about creating a price just for you
from at them boys pick up Gage Shepard
or Renfro out of that group I would
still have to lean Hunter Renfro he's
the guy that could still be you know a
big upside pick in this offense any
given week Devonte Adams is going to get
his sanitarium Waller but the having
again a legit number two maybe a number
one pass game option in a given week
gotta feel good about it what three
stars am I avoiding this week a little
bit early guys I still needed to get you
know more of my research done for all
these matchups is just Tuesday after all
but I will say that you know just
looking at these two back committees
that are going back and forth the Rams
the Dolphins yeah I want most I want
Acres these guys should not be on the
waiver wire that said we don't know what
it's going to look like in week three
and even Houston seeing Rex Burkhead go
from the Undisputed rb1 to Damien Pierce
taking every single backfield Carrie
when we have these offenses that have
just been flip-flopping their usage this
drastically to start the season we gotta
accept that we just don't have the
strongest feel on it just yet I'll be
answering the majority of star sick
questions with these Rams these dolphins
and with those Texans running backs with
the other guy
from afresh thoughts on Kyle Pitts it
sucks feel free to curse Arthur Smith
chill okay don't sell low on Kyle Pitts
he's still a rookie his second year
tight end coming off a rookie season and
would she disappointed because our
expectations were already up here but
still had a thousand yards so Drake
London's looked fantastic it does seem
like he's going to be the number one but
come on do we really think a limited
Zacchaeus is going to be consistently
working ahead of cow pits All Season I'm
holding on to Kyle pits I'm going down
with the boat Don't Panic it's been two
weeks two terrible weeks I hear you I
have a lot of Kyle pits too stay calm I
think we'll see some big things I did
check though unfortunately the Falcons
don't have a game in London this season
so we're not going to have that boom
from at and Martin pick up golf to
replace Brady I wouldn't replace Brady
unless I'm missing some sort of crazy
injury that just happened that'd be
terribly unfortunate but I don't hick
off again I would say went to uh even
James are guys that I would probably
prefer just a little bit more over Jared
Goff at this point but Jared Goff
similar to Carson Wentz you start
putting a lot of weapons around him and
lo and behold the guys making some plays
from at T-Bone Dodgers can we trust Zeke
this week or is it time to sit Zeke to
me is like right there at James Robinson
he's a touchdown dependent rb3
unfortunately especially for Zeke right
now those touchdowns aren't guaranteed
the Zeke and Tony parlor thing that was
always with the assumption that the
Cowboys were going to be in a late
offense and last year they were the
number one ranked scoring offense right
now at Cooper Rush not terrible but also
not an offense that you should be dying
to just start guys in it's okay if you
don't start Zeke here during Dak
Prescott's absence from abess got to
start one Alan Robinson or DK Metcalf
Eileen DK it's close though true toss-up
and feel like a Rob that's fine I would
note Robinson he had one touchdown last
week he should have had two man it was
just an annoying situation but basically
like the injury you know the eye in the
sky guy they saw AJ Terrell wobbling so
they tried to blow the play dead
Stafford threw a touchdown to Robinson
like none of the players heard the
whistle but the play didn't count
because they were trying to get Terrell
off the field and just didn't injury
tent so unfortunate for a Rob just
realized that close from having a nice
two touchdown week two and I'd hate to
be the guy that you know gives up on the
Rams wide receiver too as early as we
did Robert Woods last year and remember
Robert Woods wide receiver 12 prior to
that injury
from at Rick Devonte Smith or Amari
Cooper who has the better value I'm
gonna go with Amari awesome game from
Jacoby Brissette you know last week and
I know you lose the Jets it's like how
could you say anyone had an awesome game
but this dude legitimately had five
incompletions and four of them could
have been caught and the last one was
like a desperation interception at the
end of the game so I don't think he had
a single Target to Amari Cooper that
wasn't caught and Cooper looks fantastic
out there even in week one I believe I
told you guys after not to panic just
because he had only three catches 17
yards but just the route running
continues to look on point and he was
getting interfered with left and right
so Amari Cooper someone that
unfortunately while Jacoby's under
Center I still think he's going to be a
boomer bust wide receiver three but hey
guys we start looking ahead of those
playoffs once the Sean Watson gets back
all of a sudden Cooper could be an
upside wide receiver too before you know
it I'm not so sure Devonte Smith has
that in his range of outcomes this year
from that defensive bear should I try
and sell high on Austin Eckler if you
can it's not a big deal I will say that
you know like the echler usage is
probably being overblown just a little
bit you know when the guy scores 20
touchdowns last year we're like how the
heck can he not already be on that pace
again this year but remember guys double
digit targets for running backs so hard
to find in fantasy football we're
playing a full PPR sport where guys like
Eckler they don't even need the massive
workloads that these other running backs
do because historically one target worth
about 2.7 carries continue to feel just
fine about Austin Eckler full PPR if
it's standard even half PPR I could get
maybe trying to flip him for you know
fellow high-end wide receiver full PPR
though really going to continue to be
tough to rank more than five running
backs ahead of Eckler
from its Brock Tyler Lockett or Garrett
Wilson give me Garrett Wilson uh just by
a little bit again emerging as the
number one with the Jets it's one of
those things where yeah I fully get it
Joe Flacco and moving on to Zach Wilson
maybe not the greatest but at least in
Flacco's defense guys five starts last
five starts he's gone for over 300 yards
or throw multiple touchdowns in each and
every one so I'm not saying Flacco's
Elite these days but he's been able to
put up fantasy points and style points
don't matter in Fantasyland we'll take
whatever yards and touchdowns we can get
from at bkr mural Jahan Dotson or Alan
Robinson this one's still going to be a
Rob strongly for me it's great that we
have this Washington offense popping off
but they get a tough test against the
Eagles and unfortunately dots and I
think more weeks than not he's going to
be that number three behind Terry
McLaurin and Curtis Samuel so great
promising star for Datsun on the season
unfortunately for him only one ball to
go around and that suddenly pretty
pretty talented offense in Washington
playmakers all over the place and from
at hurt Jerry time to drop Juju not drop
him he's not an auto start I saw some
people running away with you know the
Cooper cup Juju Victory laps after week
one when it looked like he was just
gonna catch 100 Balls I mean that's the
that is what it looked like in the first
half in that week one game when he
caught six or seven uh to get going he's
still ingrained into wide receiver sets
we saw the Chiefs face a juggernaut
Chargers defense I really had answers
for everything they were trying to do
other than Mahomes just doing Patrick
Mahomes things out there so JuJu he's
still someone that's going to be ranked
inside most people's top 30 top 35
receivers even if he's you know a high
floor lower ceiling wide receiver three
he's someone that I don't think we need
to you know insanely worry about and
drop by any stretch of the imagination
so Patrick Mahomes kind of warned us
about this before the year he said like
we got Kelsey and this could be kind of
a different wide receiver by the week I
believe he even shouted out two fantasy
managers specifically that was going to
be a problem so Patrick told us about it
we still have an integral part of the
chief's offense on your roster don't
drop Juju Maybe consider trading him if
you're tired of them for someone that is
you know speaking more like me and
really thinks there could be more value
but just does not dump the guy because
again I don't care who you are if you're
a full-time wide receiver in the Chiefs
offense you should probably be on a
fantasy roster so this has been be our
fantasy's way for Wired Tuesday again if
you guys didn't catch the full list top
10 real quick one more time from one to
ten priority ads owned in 350 of leagues
Garrett Wilson Raheem moster Brian
Robinson Jacoby Myers Josh Palmer
Sterling Shepard Logan Thomas Jayla
Moore and Jameis Winston and Tyler
Algiers so I want to thank you guys as
always for tuning in to be our fanciest
it's been presented by State Farm I'm
Ian Hardison Pro Football Focus and
until next time take care everybody